welcome back so today we're going to
be talking about turbulence modeling
which is one of the most important areas of high
performance computing and computational science
so when we want to design a new aircraft or an
automobile or a turbine engine the blades for
a turbine generally speaking we're going to need
to simulate some fluid flow equations to estimate
quantities of interest like the lift and drag on
the wings and the body of an aircraft for example
now we in general might want to solve
the full navier-stokes equations for
with a direct numerical simulation which would
resolve all of the scales in space and time
so here i'm going to show you one of my favorite
movies of a direct numerical simulation but it is
typically very difficult to simulate these fluid
flow equations over the entire aircraft or over an
entire automobile so instead what researchers
often do is zoom into a particular piece
like this section of an airfoil and solving the
full flow field equations for this section of
the airfoil is still exceedingly expensive
okay so this is a super computer computation
i believe it'll show here in a little bit
how many hours so this is the grid that's
being generated um and a preliminary reynolds
average navy or stoke solution is used to extract
values for the condition the boundary conditions
this is 35 million core hours okay so extremely
expensive just to get one section of an airfoil
let alone the full the full aircraft okay and so
typically it is too expensive to run direct
numerical simulations or simulate all of the
scales of the navier-stokes equations all at
once for something like an aircraft or a ship
okay and so even with moore's law of
exponentially growing computer power
it will still take at this current rate a hundred
or more years to be able to simulate the largest
scale turbulent problems at all resolutions in
space and time and that's just for one run of
the simulation now when you want to do design
optimization inverse optimization for example
to design the shape of a wing you're having to
run many many many of these simulations in an
iterative loop and so it'll be even harder to use
this for design optimization and real-time control
and so that's where turbulence modeling comes
in instead of simulating all of the scales of
the navier-stokes equations in space and time
we're going to make approximations that allow us
to get engineering quantities of interest much
much more efficiently okay so that's what i'm
going to talk about today and this is going
to lead in very naturally to modern methods
in machine learning and deep learning which is
really stands to revolutionize turbulence modeling
okay so i'm going to jump in and some of this
is going to be a review from the last few
weeks lectures so the reynolds averaging
approach to the navier-stokes equations
and we're going to kind of zoom into one
turbulent example here is to take the navy or
stokes equations in this case the incompressible
navier-stokes equations so the momentum equation
and the mass continuity equation and um what we're
going to do is look at the averaged velocity field
so this is an unsteady time varying velocity
field just like that movie i showed you but
we're going to average in time and we're going to
try to model these time averaged quantities so uh
reynolds osborne reynolds the same reynolds as
the reynolds number proposed this decomposition
of this separation of your velocity field
u which is a function of space and time
into a time averaged component u bar and
the fluctuating components u prime and so
u bar is just a time average and u prime is
everything else that's not in that time average
and the idea is we're going to take this
decomposition plug it into the navier-stokes
equations and average those equations to try to
get a simplified equation of just this mean flow
uh variable u bar and what we hope is that we get
a simpler set of equations to solve that is less
expensive but gives us large scale information
about our engineering system like the average
drag or the average lift or whether or not my
airfoil might the flow over my airfoil is going
to separate or not okay and so when you plug this
reynolds decomposition into for example the mass
continuity equation now this is a review i'm just
going to walk you through really really briefly
you essentially get six terms because this is the
divergence of u so you know partial u partial x
plus partial v partial y plus partial w partial
z or z both in the mean and the fluctuating
components and so there's a lot of tricks
we can play and i've shown you this before
if i take and i time average this entire equation
so every term here well the time average of a time
average is just itself so these three terms remain
unchanged but the time average of my fluctuating
derivatives goes to zero because those uh by
definition when i averaged them they were zero
they were everything that was not in the mean
flow so when i average i kill those three terms
which implies that my mean flow divergence is
equal to zero now by a similar argument if these
three terms are equal to zero then it stands
to reason that these three terms before i time
average were also equal to zero and so it means
that the divergence of my fluctuating components
are uh equal to zero so this is the kind
of uh game you can play when you do this
reynolds average uh navy or stoke so this reynolds
decomposition so i take my uh my decomposition
i plug it into my continuity equation and i find
these two equations that the divergence of my mean
flow and my fluctuating velocity field are both
equal to zero okay now when we do the same thing
for the momentum equation it's a little bit more
complicated so i'll just briefly walk through here
and this is going to set up the turbulence closure
problem that we're going to look at in the next
half of the video so this is just the x component
of the momentum equation so this is you know in
general three equations for u v and w so i'm just
looking at the first equation for the x momentum
and when i take my reynolds decomposition and i
plug it into my navier-stokes equations what we
find is kind of this pretty nasty expression
here this is what i get when i just plug this
into into my momentum equation and we're going
to do the same thing as before we're going to
time average everything but before we do that
we're going to notice that this term here this
u bar t that is always zero because um this
term is always zero because u bar is not time
varying so this term is going to go away
and then when we time average everything
a lot of terms drop out and i i went through
this uh kind of in another lecture so if you
want the details you can find it but basically
all of the fluctuating uh components and all of
the terms with one fluctuating component are gonna
drop out and so all that's left are these average
quantities and these quantities that have two
fluctuating components in their averages and so
you can kind of collect all of these terms
like this so massively simplified equation
but remember we wanted to find an equation that
was simpler that was just in terms of this mean
flow u bar because those give us kind of the
big average quantities we might care about
for design optimization but this equation is
not just a function of my mean flow variables
it also has these turbulent fluctuations u prime
u prime x and v prime u prime y things like that
which vary in time and space so i need to know
what's happening in the full turbulent flow field
to solve for these uh average quantities i
care about and so in general understanding
and modeling these terms here is going to
be central to the closure modeling problem
i'm going to i'm going to simplify just one
step further so you can use this identity here
which is basically just the chain rule of these
middle terms would give you the left terms plus
the right terms i've written it this way because
these are the terms that we have on the left here
and notice that every term in this right column if
i added those up it would be the same as little u
prime times the divergence of vector u prime and
remember that our divergence of our fluctuating
components is zero so these three terms die out
and so i can replace these three sums uh the sum
of these three terms with these terms here and
so i'm going to replace it like this and i'm
writing all of my partials out explicitly instead
of with subscripts and this is the u component the
x component of my reynolds average navier stokes
equations okay good so i'm just going through and
kind of showing you this is all rigorously derived
from the equations of motion uh people have been
doing this for a hundred years okay and these
terms here are called the reynold stresses and
in particular i mean the u prime u prime bar and
u prime v prime bar those are the reynold stresses
because when i take their spatial gradient
they have units of force per volume just like
these stresses down here the pressure and the
viscous diffusion forces and so these can be
kind of thought of as generalizations of these
pressure forces and diffusion forces but due to
these turbulent fluctuations they're creating
a stress on the mean flow that we want to model
good and the whole closure problem is trying to
approximate these mean flow quantities without
considering these turbulent fluctuations
so what we want to do is essentially find
a model for these reynold stresses in terms of
the mean flow that's the whole name of the game
and that's what at least reynolds average
navy or stokes closure modeling is all about
good so here are our reynold stresses um again
the x component of the momentum equation you can
do some other things i want to just show you um
we're going to go into different closure models in
a minute but there's a couple of concepts that i
want to show you that are really really important
so you can take your reynolds stresses and
we're going to try to build a model for these
reynolds stresses now so what i can do is i
can take my reynolds average navy or stokes
equations i take my my reynolds decomposition
plug it into the navy or stokes equations
and now instead of just averaging i'm going to
multiply by my fluctuating component u prime
and then average and you get something pretty
ugly here okay so i'm not going to walk you
through this you can derive this yourself or
even better go download lex smith's notes from
princeton mae 553 and you can walk through exactly
how this works but so again a lot of these terms
are going to simplify and notice that you get for
uh for these u prime u prime reynold stress terms
now i have terms that include three fluctuating
components u prime u prime and u prime sub x and
so what this means is that when i want to build
a model for these reynold stresses which are the
second moments of my turbulent fluctuations i'm
going to need to include these third order moments
these third moments uh or triple correlations
of my turbulent fluctuations and this never ends
if i took this equation and i multiplied it by u
prime and i time averaged i could get an equation
for these kind of triple stresses but those triple
stresses would have fourth order correlations that
they depend on and the fourth order correlations
would have fifth order correlations and this never
ends this is a fundamentally a mathematical
closure problem and it's kind of related to
lots of other closure problems we've seen like
the coupeman operator and things like that okay
so i just wanted to show you it's not that easy
to just you know build a simple model for these
reynold stresses this kind of just gets worse
and worse the more you try to close the problem
there is an alternative approach which i'm going
to walk through which is essentially here i'm
going to write this here so so going back to our
our x momentum equation you can write this in kind
of einstein notation like this so this is actually
all three of the equations um so u i if i equals 1
that would be the x equation if i equals 2 that
would be the y equation and if i equals 3 that
would be the z or z equation and so you can write
the whole kind of reynolds average navy or stokes
problem like this where i've pulled my partial
derivative out and all of these terms are my
stresses okay i've got my pressure my viscous
diffusion and my my reynold stresses here okay
So one of the the things that people
use the most often to model these systems
is called the turbulent kinetic energy so what
you want to do is try to understand you have all
those turbulent fluctuations how are those being
driven by the mean flow and how does the mean flow
get driven by those turbulent fluctuations so
there's this constant trade-off of energy between
the mean flow kinetic energy and the turbulent
kinetic energy and turbulence closure models are
essentially going to try to model those reynold
stresses by modeling how this energy flow occurs
only using mean flow variables so we define the
turbulent kinetic energy here k and this is going
to be the k from k epsilon models and k omega
models that you've probably heard of in the past
and with a little bit of math you can essentially
derive this turbulent kinetic energy equation
again this is done really nicely in lex smith's
course notes but this is what you get when you
essentially derive the equation for for the time
variation of k and i'm going to walk you through
what each of these terms means okay so this is the
rate of change of my turbulent kinetic energy in
time and it's driven by these these these terms on
the right so we have convection by the mean flow
essentially k is being convected by these large
mean flow currents i have pressure diffusion
i'm not going to talk about what all of these
terms mean uh i have something called turbulent
transport which again involves this triple uh
moment here this kind of u prime u prime u prime
and again subscript here u i u i 1 would be u u
sub 2 would be v u sub 3 would be w and partial
x i that means partial x partial y partial z okay
the del squared k del x square is just you know
normal viscous transport this is the term i really
want to talk about this turbulence production term
which is my reynold stresses times the gradient
of my mean flow i'll talk about this in a minute
and then i have dissipation terms basically
uh turbulence just dissipating into heat
okay and so there's this really nice figure
that i i saw in lex's notes but he pulled it
from bradshaw's 1971 book which basically
shows you know all of these different
uh terms are kind of competing to grow or to
shrink the turbulent kinetic energy and to trade
uh energy from the mean flow into energy from into
the turbulent scales and vice versa so that's what
we're going to be modeling and i'll point out this
turbulence production is one of i think the most
important for me conceptually because it says
essentially that our turbulence kinetic energy
increases when we have a large shear in the mean
flow so if i have an average flow like a shear
layer where i have really really fast flow and
slow flow there is a large shear between those
two flows that's going to drive the development
of lots of turbulent it's going to pump energy
into the turbulent scales from this big mean
flow and so for me this has been very useful
conceptually to understand what types
of features in a turbulent flow drive
the small scale turbulence so anytime the flow
separates over your wing and creates a shear layer
you know it's going to be driving lots of
turbulent energy production okay good so back
to the reynolds averaging problem and back to our
closure problem so we want to model the reynold
stresses as a function of the mean flow if we can
do that then we can solve this efficiently and we
can get mean flow quantities like the average
lift the average drag things like that okay
and the simplest approach kind of the approach
actually that people still take today this is an
old approach is called eddy viscosity modeling so
basically what you're going to do is you're going
to say that all of those tiny little uh turbulent
scales that generate those reynold stresses
they basically act like viscosity in the
navy or stokes equations they basically act
like this diffusion term here and so we want
to find kind of the effective viscosity of the
turbulence and so this was actually proposed
a long time ago by business in 1877 is that we
can model uh these turbulent fluctuations as some
eddy viscosity some effective viscosity nu sub t
times uh this kind of you know uh gradients
of the mean flow so partial u partial y
plus partial v partial x for a 2d flow like this
uh channel flow up here okay and this gets a
little more complicated in 3d you can essentially
in three dimensions write each of these components
here and i picked up this little term which
is two-thirds the kinetic energy times the
dirac delta function in case i want to look at the
stress u1 u1 bar or u2 u2 r or u3 u3 bar i'll need
to consider this term here but the big idea is
that we are modeling all of those turbulent scales
in terms of this effective viscosity this eddy
viscosity model nu times mean flow quantities
and by far the simplest model is just say nu t
is a constant so you could totally just pick a
constant tune this empirically for a pipe flow
or a channel flow or a shear flow and plug that
constant in and it will do you know all right
it's not a great model it's a pretty bad model
prandtl made a really important correction to
this eddie viscosity model which essentially
says that this this effective viscosity changes
in space depending on the mean flow shear
okay so he was considering boundary layers where
the boundary layer thickness grows and where
the turbulence evolves both you know in space
and away from the the boundary from the wall
and so prandtl proposed uh this kind of mixing
length hypo hypothesis that essentially this
effective viscosity is a function of this mixing
length squared times the um the shear in the y
direction so this kind of gradient of u in the y
direction and so if you plug this in for our eddy
viscosity you get a better model for for these
wall bounded flows okay for boundary layer flows
this is our mixing length and you can kind of tune
that empirically or make arguments for what that
mixing length is again that's like a whole thing
you would do and then there are a whole family of
more sophisticated models that try to model this
this turbulent kinetic energy more effectively
okay so so those kind of eddy viscosity
models the simple constant and prandtl
models are very very simple that's like before
computers this is what you would do now that
we have computers are these two pde or two
equation turbulence models like k epsilon or k
omega and here k again is the turbulent kinetic
energy it's that equation i derived for you
and epsilon is the rate of dissipation of the
turbulent kinetic energy so in that big tke
equation i showed you before you could basically
lump all of the terms that go to dissipate
k and you call those epsilon and then you write a
new differential equation for epsilon what causes
it to grow and shrink and you can essentially
solve these two pdes with your uh rand's equations
and you get a better uh more accurate prediction
of your of your turbulent mean field and this
would be the eddy viscosity nu as a function of
k and epsilon the the density of the fluid rho
and this constant c mu now c mu has been
empirically determined to be about .09
but this is the formula now again k epsilon models
like if you run any commercial turbulent software
there's an option you know for what turbulence
model you want to to select or to use and k
epsilon is one of the standard models but it's
been known for a long time that this is not a good
model when you have adverse pressure gradients or
reverse flow so for example if i have flow over a
wing and my wings at a high angle of attack or
it's a droop wing or there's you know a gust
i'm gonna get this separated flow uh structure
that's gonna vortex shed cause vortex shedding
and if i look at my average flow my mean flow it's
going to look like a separation bubble it's going
to look like the flow separates and reattaches
at some point and if i look at my boundary layer
profile upstream it's a normal boundary layer
profile but right in that separation bubble you
see that the flow reverses before it catches up to
the free stream so this is a recirculation bubble
or a region of reverse flow this is
called an adverse pressure gradient
that's causing the flow to reverse now
these k epsilon models are notoriously bad
for these kinds of separated flows but this is
a really important problem that people actually
care about in aircraft design is predicting when
my flow is going to separate when my wing is going
to stall that's a critical thing to predict and so
these are just not that great of models for that
okay so another really really useful model
in the literature is the spellart almiraz
almaraz model which is a one equation
model so more efficient than k epsilon
and it's actually been tailored for aerospace
applications i'm sorry autocorrect killed one
of the ls here this is two l's alma raz
here this is one of the most cited papers
in aia history so over 10 000 times this has
been cited because it's so useful and it has
very nice physical derivations of the tuning
constants of this model and again it's been
specifically tailored for aerospace applications
like uh predicting the lift and drag on wings uh
and on you know on on aircraft so you can
use this model for designing your aircraft
you know you can change or tweak uh you know
the geometry of your wing and fairly rapidly
figure out what these average quantities are going
to be and then re-optimize and redesign based on
these predictions so this one's really really
useful cornerstone of aerospace engineering okay
good so that was turbulence closure modeling using
the reynolds average navy or stokes equations
now for the the rest of this i'mgoing to tell you about a whole
different perspective called large eddy simulation, or LES
and these are really kind of the two bigfamilies of turbulence closure modeling
youhave your Reynolds averaged Navier-Stokes
andyour large eddy simulations.
And LES was proposedmore recently. So you remember Bousinesq was 1877.Large eddy simulation was proposed much
morerecently in the computational era by Smagarinskyin 1963, and Smagerinsky I believe was thedirector of the GFDL lab at Princeton
the geophysical fluid dynamics lab and so their
concern was trying to simulate and predict these
large large earth-scale geophysical flows like the
atmosphere how a hurricane forms and so again too
complicated to simulate all scales
Smagorinskyproposed that instead of solving the Navier-Stokesequations on a very very high resolution grid
wewould solve it on a much lower resolution gridand essentially low pass filter or coarse grain
the Navier-Stokes equations.  So instead of... youknow this would be far too expensive even for ourbiggest supercomputers
to solve all of the scalesof an earth scale flow, so what we're going todo is coarsen the grid and average... sorry filter
the Navier-Stokes equations onto that coarse grid
and solve those equations and when I say you know
a coarse grid I mean maybe you take the
surface of the earth and you chop it up into boxes
a hundred square kilometers or maybe a hundred
kilometers by a hundred kilometers that would
be a course model and every 10 or 20 years we're
able to refine that model down and get finer and
finer resolution because our again Moore's law and
our super computers are getting bigger and bigger
but it's still going to be a long time before we
can actually resolve all of the scales that matter
so we low-pass filter our Navier-Stokes equations
onto the coarse grid and this has its own closure
problem which is essentially the non-linearity
in the flow and i'm not going to derive
this kind of filtering it's pretty
mathematically involved but the non-linearity
effectively couples your spatial scales so your
big structures depend through nonlinear terms on
your little scales and your little scales depend
through the nonlinear term on your big scales
through that convection term in
your Navier-Stokes equations
and so we need to model what's happening under
the hood in each of these little course boxes
each of these little coarse grid boxes has
real turbulent fluid variations happening
and so we need a model for the sub grid scale
these are called SGS or subgrid scale models
and in principle we do the exact same thing for
les or or we have kind of the same tool set for
les that we did for rans we're going to use eddie
viscosity modeling and things like that we're
going to make hypotheses about what's happening uh
behind the scenes or underneath this course grid
you know in the in the full resolution field
and we're going to make approximations about
how that's approximately acting like an
effective viscosity and this goes back to
this picture of the kolmogorov energy cascade
where you essentially have you know all of these
different orders of magnitude scale separation
from the biggest vortex to the tiniest vortex
in fact the reynolds number is a ratio
of the size of the largest vortex in the
flow to the tiniest vortex so this gets
bigger for higher reynolds number flows
and you have all of these different kind of
regions where energy transfers from big scales
to small scales and medium scales and so on
there's energy transfer so the production range
again i said that turbulent fluctuations are
produced from shears in the bulk flow and the
mean flow that happens here these large structures
are pumping energy into the turbulence and then
you have these turbulent vortices splitting and
splitting and splitting this is the inertial range
and finally you have a dissipation range where the
turbulence acts effectively like a viscosity or at
least that's the model and so the idea here is to
basically just chop this off at some point don't
resolve these higher frequencies these smaller
structures and just treat them as an effective
viscosity just like we did in the rand's equations
okay good now why would we do les over rams
so here's a video i really like from think fluid
dynamics that shows an les simulation on the top
and an unsteady rand simulation on the bottom
for flow past these words and you can see right
off the bat that the les gives you way more detail
into the flow structures it's much more accurate
especially for shear structures and for the
separated region of the flow in the wake so
les is typically much much more accurate but it
is obscenely expensive it is essentially also
leveraging super computing uh super computing
resources and so there you're using you know
these huge huge super computers to run these less
simulations if you have the resources and you
really want to know about separated structures
and unstudy dynamics you know this is probably
the way to go if you can't do full dns so
another les movie i love this is um a team
from johns hopkins university stevens game and
menovo and i pulled this from the physics of
fluids group at university of tuente they're using
les to simulate the flow past an entire wind farm
again there's no way we could do direct numerical
simulations at this scale you know for these 100
meter wings or 50 meter wings across an entire
field right kilometers long there's no way you
could do full simulation of navier stokes so
they're going to do large eddy simulations to
understand how these wakes interact and how the
fluid kind of vorticity interacts in this flow
and i absolutely love this video so i'm
just going to let it play for a little while
and i encourage you to download this for
yourself so you know this team is doing
great things with with les for renewable
energy and lots of other applications
but you're going to see it's going to zoom in in
a minute and we're going to again kind of see all
of the turbulent fluctuations in this flow now is
this perfectly accurate absolutely not this is not
a full simulation of the navy or stokes equations
this is not resolving all space scales in space
and time is it useful for engineering to
see how mixing occurs and how the wakes
impact downstream turbines absolutely you can
use this for design and optimization and control
i love this image where they show kind
of you can imagine a smoke line released
at a given point in time and how that
smoke would mix downstream through the flow
and so this again just wouldn't be possible
without turbulence closure modeling this kind
of full-scale simulation wouldn't be possible
if we tried to simulate the full navier-stokes
equations directly okay all right so uh one last
kind of parting thought here i pulled this figure
from uh this website cfd with a mission and they
pulled this from a set of slides by spell art so
spell art from the spell art allsmaran model at
boeing this is a great picture which essentially
shows this detached eddy simulation model or
des which was proposed i want to say in the
70s that might not be right maybe maybe later
but essentially this detached eddy simulation
is built to kind of mix the best of rands and the
best of les to be more efficient and more accurate
so when the flow is pretty steady and pretty
kind of there's not a lot of adverse pressure
gradient or separation you're going to use rands
and when the flow is massively separated like
this wake down here you're going to switch to an
les model and again lots of math lots of closure
modeling to kind of match these and combine these
but this is a very cool and useful simulation
technique as well okay great so we've talked a lot
about turbulence closure modeling and essentially
modeling subgrid scales and turbulent fluctuations
in terms of larger quantities of interest and so
in the next lecture i'm going to talk about how
we're using deep learning and deep neural networks
to start to solve and help with these rams and
les closure models to make them more accurate
and to tailor them with actual
high-fidelity data all right thank you